le titanic se trouve à 600 km à l'est de
l'île de terre-neuve
il s'agira cet été des premières
plongées vers l'épave en plus de dix ans
ocean gates a conçu un sous marin qui
peut transporter cinq personnes et
passagers qui montreront à bord du
submersible saint-trop' ste provient
d'un peu partout autour de la planète
il reste maintenant trois places à
combler pour l'expédition de juin des
places qui était auparavant occupé mais
qui sont désormais libres des
aventuriers en herbe qui ont peut-être
eu froid aux pieds
selon le meneur de la mission et
président directeur général d'auchan
gates thorton proches il ne s'agit pas
d'un voyage d'agrément
les participants doivent tous être en
grande forme pour effectuer cette
plongée vers l'épave du titanic qui se
trouve 1 4 km sous l'eau d'expliquer
stores qu'une mouche ce n'est pas un
voyage de luxe et passagers ne seront
pas traités comme ils le seraient quand
ils vont dans un centre de villégiature
5 étoiles nous avons des gens qui sont
des alpinistes
nous en avons d'autres qui ont été au
pot sud un gars a fait de la raquette
o'connor c'est un groupe varié donc mais
je pense que la caractéristique
unificatrice de tous ces gens c'est que
ce sont des aventuriers oui il ne manque
donc pas de candidats qui veulent se
frotter à cette tragique histoire nous
comme marion l'analyse avantages comme
un accident maritime puis ce sont des
erreurs de base desquels on appuie des
fois avec le temps mais c'était
effectivement pour la première fois
qu'un accident
simon lebrun pilote maritime du saint
laurent ces deux surtout analyser la
séquence des événements
ensuite leur enquête et puis ne surtout
voir à quel point cet incident de cet
accident est important parce que de
l'aîné solas une convention de l'omi
organisation maritime internationale et
qui encore aujourd'hui est la bible pour
assurer que le transport des passagers
du cargo dans la marine marchande sur la
planète entière
on respecte la réglementation
internationale
un aux éditeurs qui est spécialiste des
communications maritimes s'est intéressé
au message de détresse envoyé par le
titanic peu après avoir heurté un
iceberg
temmar 101 aux auditeurs en france une
priorité des chefs d'entreprise avaient
loué le poste de pour passer leur
message et ont leur message est que de
la vie économique que la bourse était
donc c'était ça qui était prioritaire
c'était pas les messages c'est encore
l'europe aristocratique andrée champagne
est un historien québécois à montréal
c'est ce n'est pas que ce n'est pas
qu'on les ouvriers sont carrément
exploiter c'est l'époque où la semaine
de travail c'est pratiquement 70 à une
époque où on exploite le travail des
enfants le travail des femmes c'est une
époque de très grandes inégalités c'est
une époque où il ya pas de programmes
sociaux c'est une époque où si tu
trouves en chômage technique année à la
demande et de l'ada l'assistance
publique c'est sale et pas même si les
restes des 1500 passagers qui ont péri
sur le titanic ont disparu depuis bien
longtemps
le site sera tout de même traité comme
un tombeau avec le respect qu'il mérite
par l'opérateur ou chine gates comme
l'expliquent l'organisateur stars comme
auch il précise c'est vraiment
l'expérience d'une vie des gens auront
non seulement l'occasion de voir et pas
mais aussi toute la biologie qui a
envahi le site du naufrage de 1912
un reportage de radio canada
international